Possibly the easiest way to add code to this door is by adding begin overlap triggers.
So we'll go back into our blueprint and I'll explain exactly what that means now.
We'll go to add and we'll type in vox for box and we'll type get a box collision.
Now you'll see there's a box here and we'll drag it halfway up the door and then
on the right hand side under the shape heading we'll find the box extent and the box can
be scaled in all axis X, Y and Z. So that's X, Y and Z. Z is the height in Unreal Engine.
Now we don't want to change the scale here. Normally if I was changing the width of a
door I could change the scale in Y and that would be ok. I'll set it back to one
for the purposes here. But just selecting the box again from the components list we want to change
the box extent. This is because when we're looking at code and this is later down the line you
don't necessarily have to worry about this for now but when we're looking at more complex
code generally programmers use the box extent for good reasons and calculating different math
properties and the scale isn't necessarily something they can adjust. So if this stayed at 32
and I had changed the scale to 4 for example well we still get that vertical height but the scale
is the wrong way to manipulate a box component. So again nothing to worry about too much and if
you did change the scale for this example then it wouldn't be an issue the blueprint would
still work but let's just try and let's do it the correct way that we would moving forward
and so say we give it 100 in Z and maybe we do 50 in Y well let's maybe go more like 70
and then maybe want a depth of say 70 again let's try not 700 we want to go 70 and essentially
what we're doing we're putting a box radius around this if I deselect the box for a second
we can see there's this box created around and this will essentially detect when the player is
close to the door and when the player is close to the door i.e when they hit this box we can
add some functionality to that door. So I've gone for 70, 70 and 100 again you can eyeball it by
just scaling the values like this however you'd like to do it the box can be as big as you'd
like it just don't make it too small and make sure the player has enough room to bump into this
box so we'll compile and save and there's going to be a couple of organizational things I want
to do here I want to make sure that the door frame is there I want to get the door
and I think I want to drag and drop the door underneath the door frame so this basically
childs the door to the door frame therefore when I move the door frame the door will move with it
so that's nice functionality the only thing I want to do as well is just make sure this box
isn't childed to the door so you'll see that if we now rotate the door the box will swing
with the door maybe that's functionality you want and by the way I got to rotation by pressing
spacebar here you don't need to rotate this door but I'm just toggling through spacebar
and again going through these widgets will then toggle through that as well but spacebar is the
easiest option there so I was just checking the rotation I don't really want the box to rotate
with the door I want the box to be static so I'm going to get the box I'm going to drag
and drop it over the door this may not have happened to your blueprint and that's fine
but I think I want the box the door frame and the door don't worry too much about if
they're not in the same order and it doesn't even really matter if the door is not childed to the
door frame it's just my personal workflow so now when I rotate the door the box doesn't move with
it however if I rotated the door frame the door would come with it and that's just an example
of the parent child class and so we'll compile and save now we've got our blueprint set up
let's add some code to it